you think you think I'm not gonna make
this game easy this game it's easy oh
this part oh this part oh it's this part
everybody remember remember this one you
gotta go on the lamp the cha-cha hi or
you can do that for some reason that
works I have very little patience left
but I'm going to beat this game if it's
the last thing I do but Felix you're
just at the beginning of this game it
gets much do you see this do you see
that not anyone can do that my friend
I'm not I'm calling you a friend out of
charity alright you are mayor a viewer
to me that's right listen up I'm tired
of this [ __ ] I'm tired of this [ __ ]
mountain I'm tired of everything you
have to reap what is it there's some
sand on my mouse pad so I'm having sand
in my go away Apple okay so here we go
this is it
this is quite the this is quite the SH
debacle as we say in Sweden you know
what that it what a sh debacle
you gotta gently push her up no you
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] I am so [ __ ] tired
of redoing this [ __ ] here we are again
everyone it's an it's great this is just
great we just get to get to know each
other you and me mr. taebel know we get
to know each other quite well a little
bit more than I would like and by a
little bit I would say an eternity
approximately oh gosh alright keep it
cool Felix you've got this my man my
brother my neighbour
good job Felix what the [ __ ] how are you
slipping there how are you slipping
there my fam
if you slip there
you definitely gonna sleep anywhere else
all right here we go this is the
ultimate test of slippery as I like to
call it try to make sure that I have as
much mousepad to work with as just
huming Lee
okay we're falling but it's okay that's
okay it's gates okay it's okay oh Jesus
oh okay we're fine
we just got a we got to get up there
again don't fall down because I'll be
[ __ ] annoyed thank you it's just a
test of slippery it's a test of slippery
a test of slippery are you slippery or
are you a [ __ ]
hey that's not good enough is it may
have spit all over my wall
no it's Kate don't panic don't panic
don't the hell how did the orange come
back go away ruin my life that's stupid
orange stop where's the game journalist
difficulty when you want it huh
[Music]
okay okay
ah yes I'm back to game you can glitch
out that's the cat everybody you can
glitch out as much as you like buddy as
much I'm gonna come back I'm gonna come
back I'm just [ __ ] gonna come back is
what we need to do now obviously is PO
go up and grab that bat cat's head the
first time you play this game pogoing
can be really scary especially because
if you spaghetti it you can clearly like
push off the right side and then you'll
just go to the left side and you'll have
to start over again so we're just
wanting to Pogo up and reach around and
grab the top of this oh my god oh wow it
looks like you're a [ __ ] good walk
through [ __ ] idiot oh no oh I need
help I'm scared this is not that bad
this is not that bad I know I can do it
I've done it many times I know I can do
it I have faith in myself by the power
of God and anime on my side it's not
that hard it's really it's not it's not
that hard it's actually quite easy the
more I think about it it's laughable
that I've been struggling on this bit
because I mean let's get real here
everyone mina-san this bit is quite easy
it's it's like making love to another
chicken the chicken may think wow this
is this is great and so
may you thing but the FBI may think
something completely different which
it's honestly which is honestly just
just like how it is to play this game I
think it summarizes it it quite well
quite well you got to get the fest a as
we call in Sweden yeah you know what
that means yeah you [ __ ] do well it
doesn't mean scat Oh God
let's not do that again okay here's what
I'm gonna do I'm gonna imagine drawing a
circle a perfect circle okay and we're
gonna draw a circle and we go down no
okay all right
sometimes when you draw circles in life
it doesn't always work out and that's
fine that's fine
my hands are like sweating I'm solving
the drought crisis in California maybe
I'm trying too hard
maybe I just need like a little bit oh
okay that actually that actually makes
sense
I did it I used my great superior mind
and I did it so what I've been trying to
do is like ah but now I try to like just
lift down instead and I made all the
difference
thank God okay I think I think I think I
think I can do it now I can climb this
church I can climb it the church I am a
Swiss tchen Channel and I can climb that
church mr. cat I'm not gonna make the
same mistake that I might it's so weird
I know what the mistake that I make is I
know perfectly what I need to do
perfectly but the [ __ ] cat hey it's
the thumbs up of death everybody isn't
that nice yes and dad just Voronezh
oh it's a good skates gang ooh oh look
at that it's so easy let's do the same
thing twice you tried to slow is better
than too fast remember to slow is better
than too fast to slow is better than too
fast you're the turtle channel your
inner turtle pills you [ __ ] [ __ ]
like honestly to flow is better than too
fast that's okay I was a little too fast
there but whatever there it is hey
mister thumb want a glitch out again on
me
[ __ ] [ __ ] oh I actually I'm stuck
okay
nope Jesus Lord olds thumb II listen
I'll would stick that up my ass if it
meant that I could complete this I'm not
joking too slow it's better than too
fast
yes oh yeah come on too slow it's better
than too fast yes almost
[Music]
almost over Felix it's almost you're
almost over at the worst part come on
come on come on show your squad fam that
you're a real man
what the [ __ ] was that god dammit I'm
imagining babies turning into fountains
of gold think of the babies and the
golden fountains think of the babies and
the golden fountains what in the ass
[ __ ] II was a
don't push away you sucking nipple Terry
twister babies and mountains babies and
mountains babies and mountains babies
and mountains babies and mountains
babies and mountains what do I do here
babies and mountains he's gonna slide
down isn't he
babies and mountains babies and
mountains we are so close
get over it first summit first celebrate
later so close my god I am going to die
please just just ice yet I did it I did
it my [ __ ] you thought I couldn't do it
did you leave a like leave a like leave
a like get this to trending get this to
trending come on everybody if we all
work together it's quite famished